and then girls will have this awesome
outfit with this dress you know
Christmas dress it hugs their hips and
then their matching green opaque tights
and then just like Dick Morris that's a
party what I said if you dig more is
that's a party
I don't like socks at a party I don't
like engaging in dialogue with people
with my little soft fuzzy cotton toes
sitting around you need to have shoes on
at a party and that is why I left go
back here in America I will never take
my shoes off ever so glad to have this
next guest it wouldn't be the end of
your show without one of my fellow
rebellious Canucks of course you know I
must the Anthony Akoo Mia network rebel
TV host of the Gavin McGinnis show I
don't know what else to say
Gavin McGinnis that's the man who I'm
talking about Gavin thank you for being
here I'm happy to be here Stephen grout
er what's why is it what does that an
attempted a joke why can't you do a hard
C on McInnis Gavin McInnes
not McGinnis did I say McGinnis yes you
did and Siri even says McGinnis everyone
says I think it's the way North
Americans use a see they're so lazy it's
like sorry live McGinnis Kenneth McInnis
what if there was a C and then a big C
McInnis C in a big G it would be
McGinnis all right I'm sorry all right
listen I'm not people are listening
already so let me reintroduce um Gavin
McInnes the prick thanks for being here
Gavin thanks for having me Steve and
Rick Crowder the big problem you know
what I get all the time I get chowder I
just had that a stand-up gig in San Luis
Obispo someone's like a chap it's not
it's not like come on McGuinness because
I know people named the McGuinness it's
a common name it's a wrote that no one's
chowder with Crowder and that's what I
hate about immigrants and people who are
working in any kind of call service
customer service on the phone because
they don't know about the Western
history and my name Gavin McInnes which
should be a name that everyone is able
to pronounce because the Scots built the
modern world they call me Gabby inés
a vine mr. Gavin one time this woman
just she couldn't do it and I keep going
it's phonetic do you know what fanatic
McKenna and she goes do you know what
about to have your phone cut off means
oh geez you're talking with Sprint
actually funnily that you mentioned that
you know my dad has a bit of yours
that's his favorite you want to know
what it is what he liked it he heard it
on the Joe Rogan show and he actually
quotes it a lot now we were big quoters
where we get in a theme and he liked
your but it wasn't really a bit you were
just talking but my dad's a fan of yours
and it was about the Armenian taxi
driver on the way to Joe Rogan show and
you say you know he was struggling with
English and my dad well I'll quote the
punchline I'd be an Armenian poet so
let's work in Reverse so you can explain
my dad quotes that are on the house all
the time now well I go and this happens
every single time I talk to a cab driver
or you know a car service guy they're
like what is business and I always go
are you asking is it a business then you
have to have a in front so is it a
business is a normal way to ask that
question yes is business and I go where
are you from
oh well there would be like Echo Park
but no no how were you from before that
over in Glendale probably how long have
you been here for 20 40 years 24 years
if I lived in Armenia for 24 years I'd
be writing whatever stupid krill axilla
clang would you have with my feet and
I'd be an armenian poet by now if i
lived in japan for 23 years I probably
wouldn't even speak English anymore I'll
just be counting money going what a
sauce would okay okay no so yeah kind of
buzz when you also be you'd be jumping
off a rooftop why well it's the highest
suicide rate in the industrialized world
just tons of plummeting tiny asian
bodies I would do that as a testament to
their culture they edited that from read
I once when we were talking about it and
no one knew that sometimes and we talked
about this Alessa Mo's in the program
sometimes people don't necessarily know
the data from which I'm working I assume
everyone knows it's the highest suicide
rate in the world but I guess a lot of
people don't and so I made a joke on
red-eye and I just said well beware the
tiny plummeting Asian bodies it's a
pandemic there I hear
and next thing you know it was cut and
it was really awkward they're like well
that's just really that's the highest
suicide rate that's the way they commit
suicide they'd it's the highest
concentration people who jump off
buildings they're like now we can't run
that I thought it was funny you know
suicide is it's a hate fact that's what
I hate hate facts when you say something
that's true and someone says well we're
not using that
like I've had trouble on TV when I say
over 25% on even the easiest polls say
suicide bombing is sometimes or often
justified with Muslims and they go what
what is that data again and I think why
don't you know that data everyone should
know that number 60% the low number is
25% and they go no we're not doing that
it's too too controversial but facts
aren't controversial well yes they can
be that's the problem yeah that everyone
gets offended with something well you
keep adjusting your Canuck hat for
people who are listening to rest really
it's so hot I don't understand how these
young kids today we can wear beanies all
day that's a wool hat well I'm going to
be honest I literally just got off the
air too I was working out before coming
in here and I'm probably pretty flushed
as well so we're sharing it's like et
where both our flowers are going to wilt
at the same time it's a horrible film
right don't be so negative
don't be so negative it's sure you were
just yelling at your producers before
coming on air I was like a Bill O'Reilly
outtake oh that's not true I was telling
them they did a wonderful job and I was
thanking them for all their hard work I
think what do you think a jury would you
rather work for Gavin McInnes
or defended Kinnison your temper at work
that Bill O'Reilly clip you're talking
about I watched that and I go he was
pissed off the teleprompter was not
working perfectly normal or that guy
from i watch it and i go i watch it and
i go you've worked at Inside Edition for
a decade and you don't know what it
means to play us out come on come on you
have to admit that like that's Ron
Burgundy ask whatever you yell at people
that's what men do in the workplace we
say what the hell is your problem and
slap them around it's healthy only if
they're women and/or minorities so we
were going to have you on the program
and this is one thing I tell people you
know you've got a big mouth you talk a
lot because you're Gavin McInnes so do I
so I'm like I'm always garden who I
trust but
do have a heart and sometimes because
you come across this bombastic people
don't necessarily realize that but you
were actually willing to come on this
show with my mother from this last week
I told you you know her mom her aunt
passed away socialized health care was a
real struggle but she's still pretty
tender hearted about it so I didn't want
to bring her into it
but it's something that we can talk
about for days on end now to be truthful
socialized health care didn't kill my
aunt what did happen was it took so much
longer to get a diagnosis and then to
see the right doctor who could determine
the course of treatment where you know
when you're dealing with lung cancer as
most people in Quebec do 10 14 weeks can
be a lifetime and it was really
heartbreaking so he was willing to come
on which is really nice in but do you
have experiences yourself of any family
members and socialized health care who
just don't realize how crappy it is oh
yeah and and I was born in Britain and I
up in Canada so I've seen it happened
twice you know in two different
scenarios and it's both the exact same
problem remember my grandmother needed a
hip replacement and she had to wait
years and she goes see these bloody
emigrants they're getting started before
me I've been painting this my whole
bloody life because I shouldn't have a
health count I should have a platinum
elf count and you know immigrants were
getting treated before her because of
whatever you know crocodile tears seized
they had because they felt bad about I
don't know what what Scotland did to
Pakistan but they have to pay them back
with free health care and all kinds of
favours and you know immigrants take
advantage of that and bring in their
sick parents and all in in all three
countries in America Canada and Britain
yep and there's this misnomer where they
just assume that in Canada you just walk
in and sit down and they treat you and
you walk out no because it's free there
is no incentive for them to serve you in
a timely fashion so you go to the back
of the line just like you do for
groceries in Venezuela and it's it's
very dangerous in terms of cancer
because cancer is a time bomb right we
can handle this we can handle this we
can analyze once it's like a computer
virus right once it metastasizes there's
nothing you can do right yeah no exactly
right and I actually had a comment on
the Facebook post and I hate to do this
but you know
you're the same way I'm pretty authentic
with the audience so a lot of people
know they're going hey how's your aunt
and I said well you know let me just do
this all in one shot Facebook Twitter
boom get it over with and let everyone
know and move on and I had a comment
from someone from high school this is
what leftists do I mean you listen I
don't believe it's never too soon for a
joke but goes well you know I'm sorry
about your aunt but Maya needed a hip
replacement and it would have cost
$20,000 in the States
she got it for free so f you bro
remember where you came from firstly
it's not free secondly great a hip
replacement and you got it and you
waited a long time it doesn't fix the
problem like you said with cancer one
thing people cannot refute and I'm sure
you have the data on this if you have a
life-threatening disease a
life-threatening illness your single
best chance of living through it the
single barometer that we have to
indicate you will survive is do you live
in the United States of America
regardless of wealth love wealth level
regardless of ethnicity across the board
yeah I mean look at vets if i was a sick
mammal in canada i would rather be a dog
because you are going to get the best
care in the fastest way possible because
the free market has incentivized
efficient care i don't even think it's
legal for canadians to come down to
america to get treated and a lot of them
try to do that a lot of them will do it
illegally I think they will now pardon
me
I think it's legal not well you know now
they have super hospitals in Canada
since you and I moved away did you know
about that no yeah so there's actually
super hospitals there was a Supreme
Court case in show.we versus Quebec in
2005 I left the note 4 and wasn't no no
it wasn't no 4 I actually left I guess
after the case but I didn't know about
it because I hadn't built the hospital
yet so in the West Island of Montreal
it's called a super hospital or as we
know them here in the States a hospital
where you can actually just pay for
health care but there's really yeah yeah
but you have to pay an annual membership
and it's I don't know what the numbers
are it's very expensive like a $900
annual fee and then a fee basically kind
of like a concierge doctor so who can
afford it I mean you think about the tax
burden and the cost of living in a place
like Montreal not many people can afford
that kind of care especially since
they're already paying for the
socialized carry out-of-pocket $900 a
year well before you even see anyone
just as a one-time membership it's
something high like that I pay that for
my family plan once well no no it's it's
a
in addition to socialized healthcare and
then if you see a doctor it's 150 or
whatever treatment so you're still
paying for everything else but you have
to pay a one-time fee to be a part of
this super hospital with with a 52% tax
rate if you're making 60,000 a year or
whatever it is so not a lot of people
can afford it but yeah they have it was
actually violated it was ruled a
violation of Human Rights
Gavin not civil rights Human Rights
because Shelly was serving people in
Quebec privately who were going to die
and he was helping them and when he was
put out of business the court said
actually it's a violation of Human
Rights to tell people you have to go in
line and die if they're willing to pay
for healthcare so that's a monumental
shift since you and I left it is
stunning and it's it's if there's one
place the free market will help it's
when your life is at stake I don't even
think there should be an FDA I think all
drugs should be experimental maybe you
get a little sticker on it if it's
passed some sort of test but when drugs
work they become popular you know what's
happening with my peers is they have all
this incredible healthcare and they're
refusing it
because they've been brainwashed into
thinking that it's not as simple as
radiation chemotherapy blast that
bastard the only way you can kill cancer
is to nuke it but I grew up punk rock
and all my sort of idols and now friends
are dying because they've been
brainwashed into thinking that the free
market and the government are not the
government but that the the hospitals
the oncologists don't know what they're
doing and you had Ari up from The Slits
right yeah I refused to get a mastectomy
and said I'll handle it I'll go to
Jamaica and smoke some herbs mom she
changed her mind at the last second too
late it had metastasized she's dead
polystyrene from x-ray Spex exact same
story I'm too Punk to get treatment on
no it's all a lie there our big business
wants to shut you down its corporate
it's all corporate now you could just
use creams no you can't mantra you could
just use creams yep any rainbow a friend
of mine who started crass he had some
sort of cancerous thing in his jaw he
was using cream on it and they're
holding crystals and stuff it's all this
hippy cream of work right you guys just
get some cream on it
I implored penny I go stop it with the
Asian medicine these guys think that
like a bear's gallbladder is gonna give
you x-ray vision stop they have 3,000
years of terrible light it's exactly
sure I go how often have you ever been
to China they're literally like the
Chinese who come into Hong Kong right
cuz I don't consider my Chinese in Hong
Kong they hold their children above the
trashcan to go to the bathroom there do
rednecks in China people don't think
there are rednecks anywhere but even the
mainstream culture has like a tiger's
eye lash is gonna make you live longer
make you more virile cuz it's a tiger
night oh we have to go to break I think
he's confusing China with hocus-pocus
but the actual film they did use a
tiger's eye lash to cast that spell
Gavin McInnes after this stay tuned we
are back with host of the Gavin McInnes
show over at the Anthony cumbia Network
is an Anthony ku Mia network or what's
the type what's the website that's the
network on it's on Anthony ku Mia calm
Anthony cumbia calm and they make far
much far much they make much more money
than we do because they have you people
paying the Crowder heads aren't willing
to pay for their content how dare you
glad to have you here it's funny we're
talking about that before we go firstly
I want I want to move on right after
this because you run the risk of people
saying that you're simply an SI
immigrant but yeah
China China has never gotten it right
they've never gotten anything right and
never gotten medicine right they've
never gotten government right as they
built an empire at one point where they
were more advanced in technology but
certainly from a moral standpoint
they've not gotten it right and it's one
of those things where people love to go
over there or India as a perfect example
they go there to find themselves
spiritually also some want to be yogi
from the Upper East Side can slap the
religious symbol on a bumper sticker and
feel good about themselves when these
people would give their left arm to be
American for a day I don't understand
the Chinese medicine like you said with
cancer I know a lot of people too who
really who really believe it not saying
being healthy doesn't help
supplementation can't help of course it
can but we have modern medicine the
thing about the double-blind
placebo-controlled clinical trial it
tells you what works yeah and the the
guy I was talking about is the founder
of the San Turkish punk band called
crass penny Rimbaud and he's a big
animal rights activist he probably
hasn't eaten eaten
in 60 years and this guy's still all
into Chinese medicine oh I'm seeing the
top Chinese herbalist in the country
who's white of course and I'm thinking
no one treats animals worse than the
Chinese I mean there are two models with
food or if it moves its food and the
more pain and animal suffers while it's
being killed the more delicious it is so
why are you doing this and the reason is
because the liberal ethos is f no
masochism it's I hate the Western world
and it's I hate capitalism if what if
there's any other option they will go
for that and this is particularly
dangerous in medicine because if there's
one thing we are good at its antibiotics
chemotherapy blasting cancer look I got
this bite on my arm on the weekend oh no
and it's a little it was a mess and I
pulled out of my forearm I guess you
can't see that I can see it I can see
this is HD so this is HD son it turned
into a bull's-eye this morning and I
just went oh crap I got Lyme disease so
what do I do I'm headed down to the
clinic where I'm on this weird thing
called Christian health ministries where
you pay no I know what it is yeah
there's a shared amount versus as
opposed to like deductible yeah
but you have to but you also have to
commit to not drink too much or do drugs
or smoke or you know sold and this this
pulls I've had Lyme disease I don't take
antibiotics but speaking of and I keep
bringing up these far far left II type
of punk rockers because they have the
same sort of mental disorder that all
liberals have is just exaggerated and
you got Kathleen Hanna from Bikini Kill
and leti grrah she had Lyme disease and
I believe she just had some sort of like
cool Punk doctor deal with it and if you
don't get Lyme disease that day and let
it go say a year it becomes in the same
zone as multiple sclerosis like yeah
every few months you are virtually
paralyzed and that's what happened to
her this is what keeps happening these
people that think capitalism and big
business are evil and I've got a better
idea
screw you I'm gonna use cream well
what's so funny is actually really far
the other way they sort of come back and
meat so to give you an example my family
doctor who we visit in Texas he's just a
general practice just a family doctor he
doesn't deal in insurance at all at all
$50 you see him my brother actually had
minor surgery performed by him on his
ear I think for about $250
so in and out no insurance like $300
what he had was you know it's pretty
common for a sebaceous cyst to have a
problem there and have to operate that's
why pirates actually got ear piercings
did you know that they believed there
were health benefits and they happen to
get it right they didn't actually know
any what we're gonna say something
surfers ear they get surfers get that a
growth just grows that seals the ear and
you get this major operation to get it
out well I don't know what was something
like anyways my brother had it for not
much money but one of my family members
actually and I had not high cholesterol
I had high overall cholesterol though my
ratios were great so this is a doctor
who's totally Western medicine he can
prescribe anything but he goes well you
know what let's do this let's get you on
this these fatty acids this fish oil and
with my mom who had some higher
cholesterol he got her on some
supplementation he goes we're gonna come
back and do the blood work it was better
than if they went on any kind of a a
prescription medication you said okay
great this is great so here's your diet
now eat oatmeal you're fine eating eggs
lower down the refined sugars and your
cholesterol looks great
kept checking up on her didn't prescribe
her because in an absent have someone
coming in pushing an insurance company
doesn't have some pharmaceutical rep
coming in now that's exactly what these
Eastern medicine fans should like but
they support the Affordable Care Act
which is what one big kick back to big
insurance companies they don't
understand that the concierge doctor the
cash only doctor the no insurance was
what we had forever until recently and
the modern pharmaceutical complex is a
byproduct of big leftist government well
half these doctors don't even know what
they're charging
I've asked cuz I don't care before I had
kids I did cash all the time and
wouldn't even have health care and I'd
ask doctors how much this is costing and
they go I don't know and I go could you
give me a ballpark is it $200 or $2,000
and they go I have no idea right well I
give a good example two MRIs I had to
have MRIs done all the way down my spine
from these wrestling injuries and is it
occurred to you you're a hypochondriac
you have had more medical testing than a
90 year old woman well I actually what
happened is actually in New York I
actually have two ruptured discs and
some pretty pretty serious problems with
the back so but no I just I just checkup
he's like well your cholesterol is a
little high you know he always just
tries to keep you healthy as opposed to
correct a real problem but I didn't have
some wrestling injuries and we're
probably looking at some surgery soon
you just
to me from the point Gavin I mean you
and your suspenders in your pants I
don't know why you're wearing pants for
this interview you should be I'm not
wearing pants
connected to my underwear it's not fair
and that's not true look Oh Gavin let's
see Gavin let's see Kevin want me to
prove what I'm wearing yeah cuz I saw
you wearing pants early you're pulling
them down right now you actually go
tighty whiteys for those listening to
rest really gamble to whiten these
Walter wedding oh my gosh stay there
stay there let's get this is a screen
shot yard there we go that's a screen
shot okay perfect
no no no no no no YouTube is gonna have
a problem with this okay back to the
point back what was my point what we're
talkin about
you're not Mercedes Guerrero lost of MRI
Oh $300 is what it cost me $300 cash if
I were doing it through insurance when I
asked was at that point I didn't have
insurance my copay would have been for
like four hundred and seventy five it
was cheaper to do cash only people don't
understand that if you work with cash
only practices and everyone but people
do pay for their own health care yep so
anyway I don't know how many times I've
heard this story from Americans where
they've called an ambulance because
they're naive and the EMT takes him a
son goes look this is gonna run you
about ten grand
so why don't we pretend this didn't
happen I'm gonna turn oh we have to go
ten seconds keep that thought back with
Gavin McInnes you were telling a story
about the EMT all about socialized
healthcare go ahead Gavin
yeah it's dumb to call an ambulance if
you can't if you could possibly not call
an ambulance we're not calling him it's
I don't know how many times I've been in
a car with my kid holding a gaping wound
with my hand as we take a yellow cab to
the hospital in a tenth of the time for
a billionth of the funny but let me get
the Armenian I've heard a lot of people
a lot of Erik ins tell me that EMTs have
sort of taken them aside and said look
man this is gonna run you ten grand you
don't have healthcare so why don't you
just take a cab you're not gonna die in
the cab on the way
it's a very very bad cut well you well I
realized last time I didn't tell you on
your show I had to leave and andrew
breitbart story we could maybe talk
about that but if you wanna hear the
story actually involves an ambulance of
how I hurt my back and just how corrupt
so this is have I not told you a story
before maybe your when you were doing
comedy and that thing your uncollapse t'
uh no that's that's what started it all
that was my knee so yeah a state well
you know if you doesn't stand up these
horrible gigs didn't collapse this stage
shifted apart my heel went in my ball
stood out I kept walking I fell over to
the ground at my shin stayed
perpendicular so just and I heard
trapped got snapped and I had to pop my
knee back in and finish but and so I've
walked with a limp literally ever since
because what am I gonna do get a knee
surgery in Canada you know how long
that's going to take I went in I
couldn't walk for four weeks like wow
it's gonna take this long I had never
gotten an MRI until I came to the United
States
I guess well maybe they did an MRI for
my pendous itis which I had removed I
don't know I don't know if they do MRIs
for ever so this way I was in New York
City at New York sports club and I was
doing rows on just and I've talked about
this in the podcast but I'll hurry it up
for you're doing rows in the machine
which I never do was the squat rack was
taken they had recently painted the grip
tape you know where your feet go mm-hmm
and I didn't know and I guess they
didn't have a dehumidifier so I was just
warming up light weight and my foot
slips off with weight while I'm pulling
it and I you hear that like this and I
fell back and if you've never actually
passed out from pain when they tried to
get me up because my back everything was
in such spasm I just saw stars and I
wasn't be able to breathe and kind of in
and out so it's very similar to when
I've been choked out in wrestling they
ended up taking me to the school to the
hospital Lennox Hill
couldn't move my legs couldn't move my
legs at all for at least 18 hours they
misread the MRI long story short it was
a ten thousand something dollar bill and
I was gonna listen I don't believe in
frivolous lawsuits but New York sports
club this was your fault just we're not
gonna pay the bill so finally they're
chasing me down I said listen I'm just
waiting to try and get the other people
to pay for the bill because this was
their fault they go oh wait you don't
have health insurance I kid you not it
was ten thousand something dollars I say
no I don't have health insurance but I
go oh hold on if you pay us $1,100
you'll never hear from us again
right cuz they're so used to not getting
paid back that they have to cut it down
a sort of like a collection agency yeah
I mean I couldn't have hired a lawyer
for that little amount so I said oh this
is what it is with Christian health
ministries you keep paying and Ann
Coulter's the one who told me about it
you keep paying as though you don't have
health insurance because you technically
don't right and then when you get it to
the right number that is the free-market
number then you send your CHS a bill and
then they refund you yeah well that's
what my dad had you know he had cancer
he has a Liberty health share and they
might actually become a sponsor to the
show and their out-of-pocket or their
shared amount is up to $1,000 and then
they cover everything else after that so
it's actually a pretty good deal I don't
know what you're paying and he had skin
cancer you had to have minor surgery on
it and they literally had a check to him
within the week and he can and he can go
to whatever doctor he wants look here's
the big picture and this is what drives
me nuts with the libs on health care
it is incredibly complex the blast
proposal we saw from Obama was what 1500
pages it's the same with climate
changing global warming all these
lefties talk about unbelievably complex
subjects like they have it all figured
out right my gut tells me the free
market is better my experience has been
American health care is better than
Canadian health care even with all the
hoops I have to jump through but I'm not
an expert and I'm not smug about it
right I just have a pretty good idea of
what would be better for everyone and
I've noticed a pattern with the free
market where it tends to solve problems
better than government but at the very
least can we ask the people involved in
this debate not to be so self-righteous
about it all well especially as people
die in Canada so that was the
jumping-off point what is on you what
else do we want to talk about here in
this segment because we talk about
health care I could talk about it all
day but I know people get bored uh well
we're approaching Christmas here and I'm
seeing all these colleges refuse to
mention Christmas you know I like to
have a holiday party there was a
university here I think it was Cornell
that said make sure that your holiday
party couldn't be Cano
University of Tennessee ensure your
holiday party is not a Christmas party
in disguise
real Ohio State University wants to make
sure you avoid red and green bows and
this is becoming more popular there was
a high school principal you-jin Kim here
in Brooklyn who has banned Pledge of
Allegiance
anything sand to eat anything Christmasy
Thanksgiving basically anything Western
that has a hint of judeo-christian
values and the irony is that's why you
came here that's what made this country
great right we're not saying you're not
allowed to be an atheist go bananas
atheist but it's worth a little bit of
respect
looks like we were talking the other day
about you know if I had moved to Japan
if I move to Japan take my shoes off
when I go indoors if you were living
here in the West wait wait hold on
you're french-canadian don't you take
your shoes off when you go inside anyway
no really that's why I left Quebec that
would I don't understood walk through
dog crap and gum and and you're out
there in Brooklyn so whatever hipsters
leave on the floor I'm assuming broken
needles and cigarette and American
spirit cigarettes butts and you drag it
through your house I walk through dog
crap once a year and it's a major
catastrophe a full alarm alert there's
garden hoses involved toothbrush gets
sacrifice no there's constant
microscopic dog crap especially in New
York
Oh microscopic dog crap is not an issue
here I could lick my shoes when I get
home it's not like I'm covered in gunk
Montreal you're walking on slush and
snow and then you go to a party and not
only do you have to take your shoes off
so now you're walking around in socks
and it's so hard to be a man when you're
walking over to the kitchen with your
little sock useless because you're short
so you need to lift but then the girls
they have this awesome outfit on with
these stiletto boots sorry I missed your
joke and I think that's because you're
short so you prefer the lifts go ahead
oh I see
yeah that's a fact sure that's
definitely a factor and then girls will
have this awesome outfit with this dress
that's you know Christmas dress it hugs
their hips and then their matching green
opaque tights and then just like Dick
Morris that's a party what said if you
dig Morris that's a party I don't like
socks at a party I don't like engaging
in dial
with people with my little soft fuzzy
cotton toes sitting around you need to
have shoes on at a party and that is why
I left Quebec here in America I will
never take my shoes off ever but you
wouldn't Japan I went in Japan and I'll
tell you being married to Indians my
wife Oh is always barefoot in the house
and all the kids the second they get
home they take off their shoes and their
socks I'm like what is it with you
Indians and being barefoot all the time
when we say Indians do we mean forehead
Indians or do we mean red man Indian
feather not dot feather not dot okay
yeah I was reading an interview with
this American Indian who was on a
volleyball team and she's famous now and
she's making money and she goes do you
ever miss home she goes yeah I miss the
res I miss being barefoot and wearing
sweat pants and feeling the dirt on my
toes and I'm like even some stranger in
another tribe miles away the first thing
they go to is barefoot people in the
West if it's not snowing out you need
your shoes on at all times if you're if
you're at home you're gonna be stepping
on your children's Cheerios there's
gonna be other things on the ground
you're gonna stub your toe so your
concern is Cheerios on your feet not dog
feces on your carpet that's where we
part ways no your problem is you're
assuming there's rampant dog feces
everywhere yes yeah it's like stepping
on a dog it's a huge deal no it's not
it's all over the place in New York
there's all kinds of crap and it's
everywhere it's a it's a filth in the
only way you can make dog crap appear on
my shoe is to say it's microscopic which
means it's a microaggression and I can't
disprove it it's too tiny but as far as
chunks go right away and it reeks up the
whole room there you go Gavin McGinnis
does not believe in germ theory any he
is your wife completely hairless is she
did she get that part of the yeah she is
Indians are low on body hair I will say
that yes we're getting a little personal
you are the most forthcoming person I've
ever known you will talk about benders
that got me about my life
I'll stand up nude right now and do a
hula dance for you to do that but it is
true I the one Native Americans I knew
and I guess I don't know if they were
Inuit and can nobody here zero none no
one believed him and I don't know if
that was across the board
they're very Asian that way it's hard to
tell them apart with the same eyes -
yeah it's hard to tell them apart if you
talk like Mayan Indian Native American
like they can be interchangeable well
I've always said you're not an American
Indian if people don't ask you whether
you're Asian or Mexican because there's
so many of these white guys with blonde
hair getting checks up in Canada because
they're one one-thousandth mohawk it's
such a scam you have to be a quarter or
nothing well you know what's funny about
that is it's proof that there was no
mass genocide most of it occurred
through integration there was constant
intermarrying they were encouraged to
take the Native Americans convert them
to Christianity bring them into the
European Way of life and some of them
didn't want to so the idea that we came
in and deliberately wiped him out well
then how was Johnny Depp 118th Comanche
or whatever it is that doesn't happen
look I've been making Indians from
scratch since oh wait I can't recommend
it enough all right listen Gavin McInnes
I'll talk with you hold on after we
leave you off there where can people
best find you brother Anthony Kumi Oh
calm my Twitter is Gavin underscore
McInnis that's four put on a hat before
we go my latest projects put on the high
street
carnage comm put on the Hat before we go
so people can end on a positive note how
many seconds do we have they're not gay
Jared ten all right Gavin McInnes if you
don't like you more than a friend I like
you more than a friend we will be back
louder with Crowder stay tuned if you
like this video subscribe by clicking my
face the button above or watch one of
these other videos if you don't you are
no doubt you know what listen I know who
you are your parents call me they don't
even like you you were a mistake they
don't even want you but they said they
might feel differently if you subscribe
but these are their rules not I don't
make them I just call them